però quando nel 2009
io elisabetta ambrosi abbiamo scritto il
libro non è un paese per giovani
pensavamo di aver utilizzato un titolo
provocatorio
poi però negli anni successivi
il titolo è diventato uno slogan così
usato e abusato sui giornali televisione
sul web essere diventato praticamente
una semplice constatazione una realtà di
fatto quindi da provocazione a la realtà
di fatto di un paese per giovani a
rischio che diventi però anche un
destino ineluttabile se c'è invece
qualcosa di positivo che è successo
negli ultimi anni è il cambiamento di
atteggiamento delle nuove generazioni
momento di consapevolezza delle proprie
potenzialità e del fatto che più che
aspettare che l'italia restituisca ad
essi un futuro del diventare
protagonisti della costruzione di un
futuro per il proprio paese e quindi far
diventare l'italia un paese per giovani
nel senso di far tornare l'italia a
crescere a diventare competitiva a
creare opportunità per tutti a creare
benessere condiviso
ecco è questo quindi è l'ambizione da
cui bisognerebbe partire per farlo però
bisogna spezzare un circolo una spirale
negativa che si è creata nella quale
siamo purtroppo progressivamente
scivolato negli ultimi anni un paese che
non da spazi e opportunità e nuove
generazioni diventa un paese che in
qualche modo costringe i giovani a
rivedere al ribasso le proprie
aspettative e quindi andare di meno
rispetto quello che potrebbero dare
oppure ad andarsene all'estero ma se
forziamo i giovani a dare di meno
rispetto alle proprie potenzialità e le
proprie capacità e li costringiamo
andarsene all'estero se voglio invece
continuare ad essere ambiziosi e chiaro
che si produce in quel contesto minore
crescita e poco poca spinta al
cambiamento ma con poca crescita si
riducono le opportunità soprattutto per
le nuove generazioni e quindi un circolo
vizioso che si autoalimenta e trascina
verso il basso se le condizioni dei
giovani sia le possibilità di crescita
del paese che è esattamente quello che è
successo negli ultimi decenni in italia
quindi rompere questo circolo vizioso e
hans innescare un percorso virtuoso come
farlo servono due condizioni
tutte e due egualmente importanti la
prima è che il paese torni a crescere ea
riconoscere le capacità e le dar fiducia
alle nuove generazioni e ad investire
nelle opportunità negli strumenti negli
spazi per nuove generazioni
l'altra condizione al 38 importante
perché è inutile mettere benzina in una
macchina che poi non vuole correre
l'altra condizione quindi che i giovani
si mettano in campo pienamente con
convinzione che scendere appunto in
campo e che credano nelle proprie
potenzialità e che si mettono pienamente
in gioco
entrambe queste due condizioni sono
altrettanto importanti se ne manca anche
solo una delle due non si va da nessuna
parte quindi il resto della mio
intervento è proprio basato su dare dati
e sostegno empirico al fatto che queste
due condizioni sono entrambi possibili
nel nostro paese e quindi può tornare a
diventare un paese per giovani nel senso
che abbiamo detto prima la prima
evidenza empirica la propongo attraverso
questo grafico che
raffigura i paesi europei all'interno di
due dimensioni e qui vedrete che ci sono
alcuni paesi che investono poco in
politiche attive e ricerca e sviluppo
asse verticale e si ritrovano come
conseguenza alti valori asse orizzontale
si trovano come conseguenza alti valori
dall asse verticale ovvero investendo
poco sulle opportunità per noi
generazione si trovano con i giovani che
sono soprattutto passivamente dipendenti
dai genitori e quindi anziché risorsa
per far crescere il paese un costo
sociale
ci sono invece altri paesi che investono
su ricerca sviluppo politiche attive e
grazie a questo si trovano nei giovani
nell asse verticale passivamente
dipendenti dai genitori e quindi
maggiormente protagonisti dei processi
di crescita e di benessere di quei paesi
l'insegnamento di questo grafico è
quindi che è possibile inserirsi
all'interno di un percorso in cui si
investa adeguatamente sulle opportunità
sulle nuove generazioni per ottenere i
migliori risultati paesi che investono
sono quelli che ottengono migliori
risultati in termini di opportunità e di
crescita
ma per farlo per ottenere frutti bisogna
che il terreno sia fertile
i giovani sono un terreno fertile che
val la pena coltivare adeguatamente
perché inutile appunto coltivare anche
con gli strumenti più avanzati un
terreno poi che non è fertile lo sono
allora c'è tutta una serie di ricerche
che riguardano le caratteristiche
l'identità generazionale dei dei giovani
sono partite dagli stati uniti
in concentrando e soprattutto sui
millenni al sì e sono gli attuali
sostanzialmente under 30 quelli che sono
diventati che hanno compiuto i 18 anni
dal 2000 in poi che è una serie di
caratteristiche che sono esattamente
nella direzione giusta
nel cogliere ad alto livello alle sfide
di questo secolo per questo sono
chiamati millennio se potremmo
sintetizzare le loro caratteristiche con
3 c la prima c è quella di connected e
questo è abbastanza scontato sono nativi
digitali sono pienamente connessi
diffusamente connessi e le è stato detto
nativi digitali
la seconda c è quella di confine hanno
molta fiducia in se stessi e nelle
proprie capacità e questo non
sembrerebbero al dibattito pubblico
italiano la terza c è quella di open to
change sono i migliori alleati del
cambiamento sono innovatori hanno voglia
di cambiare non aspettano che il
cambiamento arriva dall'alto muoiono
produrlo
poi io quindi diventare generatori di
qualcosa di diverso di discontinuità
rispetto al passato che consenta di
produrre cose nuove e di migliorare la
realtà in cui vivono oltre che la
propria condizione di vita
questi sono gli studi condotti tutto il
mondo ma vale anche per l'italia anche i
giovani italiani sono così bene
fortunatamente cominciamo ad avere dei
dati che consentono di ricostruire
l'identità generazionale dei millenni se
italiani in maniera solida non
attraverso stereotipi 3 sull'indagine
che si chiama il rapporto giovani
promossa dall'istituto toniolo che da
una serie di evidenze empiriche che
consente appunto di sfatare molti luoghi
comuni
allora il primo luogo comune a quello
dei bamboccioni abbiamo un termine molto
utilizzato che si periodicamente ritorna
è vero che i giovani italiani sono
bamboccioni
allora la diversa implica dice che non è
così è vero che rimangono per lungo
vivere con i genitori rispetto i cui
danni degli altri paesi ma è vero che
sempre di più ci provano
tanto più che il 70 per cento dei
giovani che sono usciti per studio o per
lavoro
poi sono trovate a dover ritornare a
vivere con i genitori
quindi cosa vuol dire che ci provano che
cerca di buttare il cuore oltre
l'ostacolo che molto spesso viene
ributtato indietro proprio per le
oggettive difficoltà poi di riuscire a
realizzare i propri progetti di vita
in maniera solida la mancanza di
strumenti che abbiamo detto prima di
welfare attivo e di scarse opportunità
fa sì che molti progetti vengano inizia
anche poi si debba tornare indietro ma
l'atteggiamento continua a essere
positivo e quello dell'autonomia è un
valore considerato importante da gran
parte dei giovani la 85 per cento pensa
che sia importante per potersi mettere
la prova è sempre di più i giovani
pensano anche che conquistavano proprio
autonomia riserva anche poi per non
sentirsi un peso per la propria famiglia
d'origine e poter quindi anche iniziare
un proprio percorso autonomo e
responsabilizzante sono schizzinosi e
anche qui abbiamo dei dati che non
confermano assolutamente questo luogo
comune schizzinosi nel senso che
aspettano il lavoro ideale finché non si
presenta l'occasione della vita
rimangono passivamente a vivere con i
genitori
bene invece il 47 per cento degli
intervistati che lavorano si accontenta
di svolgere un lavoro pur avendo una
retribuzione insoddisfacente foglie che
pur di lavorare pur di non rimanere
fermi si mettono comunque in gioco
accettano anche di essere pagati meno
rispetto a quello che sarebbe il giusto
una percentuale analoga accetta comunque
l'attività anche se non ha pienamente
coerente col proprio percorso di studi e
quindi di nuovo una strategia attiva
c'è la crisi c'è un contesto di
difficoltà ci si mette comunque in gioco
anche nella condizione contingente che
offre quello che offre ma senza però e
questo è importante senza però abbassare
le proprie ambizioni
come vedete il 90 per il ritorno vanta
precedenti intervistati dei millennials
il lavoro rimane comunque un luogo e di
impegno e un mezzo di base di
autorealizzazione qui devo dire nel
breve periodo accetto quello che trovo
pur di non rimanere fermo ma rimane
comunque l'ambizione di progredire di
poter migliorare
ovviamente se poi si è in grado e siano
gli strumenti adatti per poter
migliorare progressivamente sono apatici
e passivi in realtà no
il protagonismo e la voglia di essere
intraprendenti emerge in modo chiaro
anche da altri dati sento di avere
continuamente nuove idee orientata
perseguire obiettivi maniera
indipendente oltre 80 per cento dei
giovani
non ho paura di perseguire obiettivi
impegnativi ambiziosi come vedete
l'atteggiamento di partenza poi si
rischia di essere scoraggiati se si
sbatte continuamente a testa contro il
muro ma l'atteggiamento di partenza se
fosse incoraggiato e sostenuto sarebbe
questo e quindi è sicuramente qualcosa
che ci consente di avere un capitale
umano da cui partire per ricostruire le
possibilità che potesse ridare un paese
che vuole tornare a crescere
infine come vedono se stessi questo
l'ultimo dato per non tediarvi troppo
bene non si sentono né una emergenza di
una categoria da proteggere ma si
sentono la vera ricchezza del paese cioè
la risorsa principale che questo paese
ha per tornare a crescere e ad essere
competitivo non vogliono essere l'ultimo
vagone di un treno che rallenta sempre
di più e rischia di deragliare
ma la locomotiva di un paese che può
avere altre ambizioni e che può correre
raggiungendo i migliori risultati
quindi voglio concludere con velocemente
con un apologo che penso che più di
tanti dati consente poi di capire ci
aiuti a capire il salto di qualità che
dobbiamo fare come sistema paese
c'era un tempo un villaggio nel quale ha
partirà un certo anno iniziarono a
nascere bambini con un secondo occhio
alla nascita nel primo bambino fatto in
questo modo si pensa ad uno scherzo
della natura ma poi dove secondo il
terzo degli altri bambini divenne
evidente che si trattava di qualcosa di
sistematico che riguardava tutti i nuovi
nati all'inizio al ricevitore rimasero
interdetti ma poi la questione estetica
venne subito superata in fondo il
secondo occhio non li rendeva più brutti
erano solo un po diversi rispetto ai
genitori che ne avevano solo uno al
centro della fronte e poi anche i figli
degli altri erano le stesse condizioni e
quindi ben presto se ne fossero una
ragione
cosa puoi servisse quel secondo occhio
non era chiaro
in fondo fino ad allora tutti
erano vissuti bene solo con un occhio i
vecchi saggi sentenziarono comunque che
non si arriva nulla e che anzi i figli
rischiano di crescere distratti e
confusi
nessuno quindi si preoccupa di trovare
il modo migliore di vedere con un occhio
in più ai bambini crescendo si abituano
presto a terne hanno chiuso
accontentandosi ad osservare il mondo
come facevano le vecchie generazioni in
un villaggio vicino accade la stessa
cosa ai vecchi lì erano più saggi che
considerano un dono per tutta la
comunità il fatto che le nuove
generazioni si trovassero con
potenzialità visive superiori aggiuntive
rispetto ai padri cercano di capire come
aiutare a sviluppare meglio tale
dotazione innovativa e si trovarono alla
fine con giovani che sapevano cacciare
con più destrezza e costruire prodotti
più raffinati rispetto ai propri
genitori
il primo villaggio lo potremmo chiamare
conservazione del vecchio il secondo
invece promozione del nuovo quale i due
villaggi secondo noi crescerà con più
prosperità
ovviamente secondo quale somiglia di più
all'italia di oggi
ovviamente il primo ma ci sono tutte le
condizioni perché l'italia assomiglia
sempre di più al secondo
dipende solo da noi da nessun altro